le gouvernement a perdu les élections
locales départementales
incontestablement c'est malheureusement
une tradition dans ce pays les
gouvernements perdent les élections
locales
donc mon constat est national sur cette
parti- là mais je me félicite je me
permets de le dire puisque le maire de
Dijon est à vos côtés et puis Paul Robin
je me félicite du du résultat de nos
élus sur la partie urbaine de de la Côte
d'Or
où on a h élus sur 10 ou 11 ce qui fait
un très bon résultat mais je vois que la
Côte d'Or est divisée en deux finalement
il y a une Côte d'Or urbaine qui qui se
développe où on vit ensemble qui ne
craint pas trop l'avenir et qui vote à
gauche et puis un monde rural qui se
sent à tort ou à raison délaissés
abandonné à qui la faute c'est le
conseil général UMP qui gère le
département depuis si longtemps qui se
sent abandonné qui vote
non seulement UMP mais aussi Front
National et donc ce qui est plus
inquiétant ce soir c'est cette pousser
cette vague du Front national qui monte
qui monte et si on y prend garde ce
parti qui est à part dans la République
risque
d'emporter les rempards républicains et
de faire basculer l'Europe voilà c'est
ça qui m'inquiète ce soir à cet instant
et justement à ce propos on a entendu
tout à l'heure un témoignage assez
poignant on va dire de Nicolas S le
numéro 1 du PS dans Lyonne qui disait
que il lui il avait entendu tout au long
de sa campagne en porte à porte des gens
désespérés qui avait du mal à à vivre
parfois et il disait que voilà le
gouvernement devait avoir dardard c'est
son expression des résultats sinon cette
progression du Front national allait
continuer est-ce que vous vous faites la
même analyse est-ce qu'il est temps
maintenant d'avoir des résultats
j'imagine que vous allez me répondre oui
bien
sûr je vous réponds oui éc chic bien sûr
qu'il faut avoir des résultats mais la
montée du Front national ne se nourrit
pas seulement de l'absence de résultats
des politiques nationales sinon Lionel
Jospin aurait été élu président de la
République donc il y a d'autres facteurs
qui tarau de la société française il y a
les poussées d'immigration il y a la
libération d'une parole qui n'est pas
républicaine qui n pas conforme à à
l'idéal républicain qui est
xénophobe qui est raciste antisémite qui
est là il faut pas le nier euh donc
c'est toutes ces tous ces facteurs qu'il
faut analyser si on veut lutter et puis
il y a un fond nationaliste
anti-européen euh qui qui est là
également l'Europe a ses responsabilités
c'est clair mais vous savez c'est pas
uniquement en France c'est dans
l'ensemble de l'Europe que cette vague
monte et dans les autres pays on a
résolu les problèmes des fois en en
faisant les rassemblements des Forces
Républicaines européennes contre ces
nationalismes qui menacent la paix euh
dans le monde et je pense en Europe
notamment ce qui explique aussi en
partie hein la la défaite de la gauche
et qu'elle est partie bien souvent
divisée
euh aujourd'hui on a vu là ce soir que
les frondurs appelaient un nouveau
contrat de rassemblement est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui peut s'entendre
au gouvernement bien sûr qu'il faut que
la gauche soit rassemblée bien sûr qu'il
faut que la droite se rassemble quand la
droite est pas
rassemblée c'est le FN qui progresse
quand la gauche est pas rassemblée c'est
l'UMP ou le FN qui en profite ça c'est
évident mais ça suffit pas on voit bien
qu'il se passe quelque chose une forme
de tripartisme en train de s'installer
dans notre pays et ce tripartisme il
menace les fondements de la République
enfin celle que j'aime celle qui est
celle du vivre ensemble celle qui est du
partage celle qui est de la
responsabilité bien évidemment et là je
crois que une partie de l'UMP a une
lourde responsabilité en la matière
Nicolas Sarkozi en appelant par exemple
à la fin des des repas de substitution
dans le dans les écoles c'est c'est euh
c'est ce sont des choses qui font le
c'est c'est c'est ces buissonneries font
le lit du du du Front national il faut
bien s'en apercevoir entre autres il y a
beaucoup de facteurs je suis pas
simplcee et je suis pas tenant d'une
théorie uniusale il y a beaucoup de
facteurs il y a différents votes mais
enfin nous devons nous ressaisir la
République doit se ressaisir les partis
républicains doivent se ressaisir la
gauche a donné l'exemple dans ce
département elle a retiré sans hésiter
son candidat sur le canton de sœur pour
permettre l'élection de Madame coin j'en
suis très heureux je suis toujours très
heureux quand un républicain bat
quelqu'un qui est du Front national
voilà je voulais le dire clairement ici
j'espère que ça sera pareil à droite
j'ai quelques craintte de ce côté-là
c'est dit merci franç c'est Madame
directeur de la préfecture de cô d'or